Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
¿Temes a los gatos negros?
¿Abrirías un paraguas en un interior?
¿Qué sientes ante el número 13?
Creas o no en ellas,
quizá te resulten familiares
estas supersticiones.
Pero, ¿cómo es que
la gente en todo el mundo
toca madera,
o evita pisar las grietas en la acera?
Bueno, aunque no tienen base científica,
muchas de estas prácticas
y creencias extrañas
tienen orígenes extraños y específicos.
Como implican causas sobrenaturales,
no sorprende que muchas supersticiones
tienen base en la religión.
Por ejemplo, el número 13 se asociaba
a la bíblica Última Cena,
en la que Jesucristo cenó
con sus doce discípulos
antes de ser detenido y crucificado.
La idea resultante de que tener
13 personas a la mesa era mala suerte
se expandió a que el 13 era
un número de mala suerte en general.
Ahora, este miedo al número 13,
llamado triscaidecafobia,
es tan común que muchos edificios
en el mundo saltean el piso 13,
y los números pasan del 12 al 14.
Claro, muchos consideran verdadera
la historia de la Última Cena
pero otras supersticiones vienen
de tradiciones religiosas
en las que pocas personas creen
o incluso recuerdan.
Tocar madera se cree que viene del
folclore de los antiguos indoeuropeos
o quizá de quienes los precedieron
que creían que los árboles eran
hogar de varios espíritus.
Tocar un árbol invocaba la protección
o la bendición del espíritu interior.
Y, en cierto modo, esta tradición perduró
mucho después de que desvaneciera
la creencia en esos espíritus.
Muchas supersticiones comunes hoy
en países desde Rusia hasta Irlanda
se cree que son vestigios de religiones
paganas reemplazadas por el cristianismo.
Pero no todas las supersticiones
son religiosas.
Algunas tienen base en coincidencias
y asociaciones desafortunadas.
Por ejemplo, muchos italianos
temen al número 17,
porque el número romano XVII,
reorganizado, forma la palabra vixi,
que significa "mi vida había terminado".
Del mismo modo, la palabra
para el número cuatro
suena casi idéntico a la palabra "morir"
en cantonés,
así como en idiomas como el japonés
y el coreano que han tomado
prestados los números chinos.
Y como el número uno también
suena como la palabra "debo",
el número 14 suena como
la frase "debo morir".
Son muchos números a evitar en
ascensores y hoteles internacionales.
Y, créase o no,
algunas supersticiones
realmente tienen sentido,
o al menos lo tuvieron hasta que
olvidaron su propósito originario.
Por ejemplo, los escenarios teatrales
consisten en grandes fondos pintados,
que los tramoyistas suben y bajan,
y silban y se hacen señas entre sí.
Los silbidos de otras personas
podrían causar un accidente.
Pero el tabú contra el silbido
entre bastidores aún existe hoy,
mucho después de que los tramoyistas
usan auriculares de radio.
Del mismo modo, encender tres
cigarrillos con la misma cerilla
podría traer mala suerte si uno
fuera un soldado en una trinchera
y encender una cerilla tanto tiempo
podría alertar a un francotirador enemigo.
La mayoría de los fumadores ya no tienen
que preocuparse por los francotiradores,
pero la superstición sigue viva.
¿Por qué la gente se aferra a estos
vestigios de religiones olvidadas,
coincidencias,
y consejos anticuados?
¿No son totalmente irracionales?
Bueno, sí, pero para muchas personas,
las supersticiones tienen más de hábito
cultural que de creencia consciente.
Después de todo, nadie nace sabiendo
evitar caminar bajo las escaleras
o silbar en interiores,
pero si uno crece con su familia
que le dice que evite estas cosas,
lo más probable es que se ponga incómodo,
incluso tras entender lógicamente
que no pasará nada malo.
Y como hacer algo como tocar madera
no requiere mucho esfuerzo,
seguir la superstición a menudo
es más fácil que resistirse a ella.
Además, las supersticiones
a menudo parecen funcionar.
Quizá recuerdes un buen batazo
con los calcetines de la suerte.
Son nuestros sesgos psicológicos
en acción.
Es mucho menos probable que recuerdes
todas las veces que fallaste
usando los mismos calcetines.
Pero creer que funcionan
podrían hacerte jugar mejor
dándote la ilusión de tener
mayor control sobre los acontecimientos.
En situaciones donde esa confianza puede
marcar una diferencia, como los deportes,
esas locas supersticiones podrían
no ser tan locas después de todo.